thank you
[Music]
on this Friday night chilling statements
from an accused terrorist the emotional
police interview and alarming admissions
from the man who admits to intentionally
killing a Muslim family it has
absolutely no place in this country
the stress before the storm the time to
prepare is now what thousands in the
maritimes can expect as Lee inches
closer to making landfall
Sin City Giants left in limbo how a
simple phone call may have led to one of
Las Vegas's biggest cyber attacks
plus final Edition oh shocked I couldn't
believe it what the loss of a 130 year
old Community paper means for local news
I just don't want that to not be there
anymore
[Music]
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with
disturbing and shocking revelations out
of an Ontario courtroom today where the
trial of a man accused if intentionally
killing four members of a Muslim family
is underway
Salman afzal his wife Madia Salman their
15 year old daughter yumna and her
grandmother talat of cell we're just out
for a walk on a Sunday when they were
hit and killed the couple's
nine-year-old son was the only one who
survived the attack he was seriously
hurt today the jury watched a video
recording that was taken just hours
after the attack and in it the accused
tells a detective that he targeted the
family knowing they were Muslim because
of the clothes they were wearing
has a story for us tonight and we want
to warn you before we show it to you
that the details are very disturbing
London Ontario had never seen such chaos
until that fateful night in 2021 a
family had been run over four of the
five people hit were killed targeted
according to police by a young white man
who was surrounded and arrested in a
mall parking lot video of Nathaniel
veltman's interrogation by London Police
hasn't been released publicly but court
heard his explanation in his own words
I'm not planning on pleading Insanity he
told police I want the world to know why
I did what I did so I'm just going to
tell you as he begins to tell police his
story he Paints the picture of an angry
white man getting drawn into far-right
chat rooms as he said himself going down
the rabbit hole what particularly piqued
his interest were discussions around
rampant yet unreported Muslim unwhite
crime hateful claims that have been
widely discredited but those lies were
enough to set Feldman off I'm done I'm
done I'm going to commit a terrorist
attack I'm done I'm not putting up with
this anymore what happens with
conspiracy theories in these
nationalistic and white nationalism
ideas is something called social heroism
where these individuals see themselves
as someone who is battling on the side
of the Eternal on in the ultimate battle
between good and evil and what they have
to do is go out and save the nation or
save their ethnicity save whiteness
according to a statement he was inspired
by other attacks in Norway and New
Zealand when he set off in his truck
when he saw the afsoles he says he
determined they were Muslim based on
their clothes and he says he hit the gas
on his truck it was way easier than I
thought it was going to be he said the
really challenging point I think for all
of us as Canadians
is that that type of ignorance that type
of ideology can find a footing in our
country
as much as we we love to be a care
caring and kind and welcoming country
develman told police he believes he is
racist and claims everyone is I admit
that it was terrorism he said I admit it
I'm not going to like try to get a
lighter sentence by saying it was just
murder not terrorism but it's not enough
for him to say it the jury has to
believe he committed an act of Terror to
convict him that's the jury's job but
for Canadians to come to terms with this
horrific Act is another matter entirely
Mike drolet Global News Toronto
and we have in-depth reporting on this
trial from Global news's Jacqueline
LaBelle on our website just go to
globalnews.ca for more
in Alberta compensation is coming for
hundreds of families whose children got
sick in an E coli outbreak Premier
Danielle Smith says a one-time payment
of two thousand dollars per child will
be made available to parents with lost
wages and additional child care costs
there have been 337 lab confirmed cases
connected to the outbreak so far 12
children are still in the hospital six
are on dialysis Heather York's West
reports
it's unimaginable pain and I'm
heartbroken by what these family
families are going through a rare show
of emotion from the Alberta Premiere a
day after the families of hundreds of e
coli-stricken children asked why
Danielle Smith had not spoken publicly
about the massive outbreak with most
patients under the age of five the
severe symptoms and daily hospital
visits have been traumatic Alicia Loblaw
says her son is struggling to cope we
had to drive past the hospital yesterday
on route to somewhere else and
he had a little bit of a panic attack
just you know he thought we were going
back there and he was like Mommy don't
take me back I don't want to go to the
hospital I don't want anyone to hurt me
I'm not sick anymore don't put anything
in my arm lobla says she was happy to
hear families will receive a one-time
payment of two thousand dollars from The
Province to help with unexpected costs
associated with the outbreak the premier
also promising Public Health rules
related to food safety will be improved
the source of the E coli outbreak is
still not known though officials believe
it came from a central kitchen operated
by fueling mines
I acknowledge that there is some concern
that this kitchen was able to continue
to operate despite Public Health
Inspectors identifying a number of
violations the premier says neither The
Province nor Public Health officials
have the ability to close facilities
unless critical violations are found and
after correcting two infractions last
April the kitchen had been compliant
with all rules
I would have expected in a high risk
area like this that there would have
been another inspection and indeed if
there was an infraction found temporary
closure would be appropriate
coli cases could rise doctors are
hopeful
children has stabilized with 12 young
patients still in hospital work now
continues on finding the answers needed
to ensure this doesn't happen again
Farah
Heather York's West in Calgary thank you
heather
dangerous weather is at the doorstep of
Atlantic Canada as hurricane Lee
approaches the storm is set to make
landfall in maritimes tomorrow and
officials are warning residents not to
underestimate it
while the storm may be weakening it is
still a significant storm so we need to
be ready I want to take this opportunity
to remind Nova scotians if they haven't
already done so the time to prepare is
now
hurricane and tropical storm watches are
in effect throughout Nova Scotia and New
Brunswick Environment Canada is also
warning of flood risks and the potential
for storm surge along the coast our
Global News chief meteorologist Anthony
Farnell is in Yarmouth Nova Scotia
tonight Anthony what's it like there
right now
far it's actually been a very nice day
here in Yarmouth there was a light
Breeze the Sun was shining but within
the last couple of hours those clouds
are thickening up and rain is knocking
on the door that's what comes first and
then as we move through the night
tonight we're going to start to see
those winds gusting 60 first and then up
to 90 and by tomorrow morning possibly
110 kilometers per hour and that also
means some big waves and a storm surge
just off the coast behind me especially
to our East as we're dealing with the
Atlantic side that could have 8 to 10
meter waves crashing just off the coast
now the reason we're in Yarmouth because
we're expecting the landfall to be
pretty close to here it's amazing that
this storm we've been tracking it since
it moved off Africa over two weeks ago
and this is the first place that it's
making landfall here in Canada in Canada
in the southwestern part of Nova Scotia
I want to show you the satellite imagery
because this system is is massive it's
no longer a category five it's only a
category one hurricane but the wind
field has expanded out hundreds of
kilometers from one side to the other
the clouds extend all the way back into
New York City and Boston today and then
up towards Newfoundland as well now the
track has shifted slightly and that is
playing an important role because the
winds now are going to be a bit stronger
around Halifax recently added to the
hurricane watch and also a tropical
storm warning for basically the entire
Province or most of Nova Scotia but this
area Yarmouth and parts of the Southwest
and the South Shore they did not see the
full force of Hurricane Fiona last year
so we are concerned about power lines
coming down tree damage and of course
that surge along with the threat of
flooding it has been a very wet summer
in Nova Scotia and that continues with
the approach of hurricane Kane Lee
pharah
Anthony Farnell and yarma thank you
Anthony
the devastation in derna in northeastern
Libya is unlike anything we've ever seen
the number of dead is staggering
according to the red crescent more than
11 000 people have been killed and it's
estimated 10 000 people are still
missing today authorities sealed off the
coastal city to give emergency crews the
space needed to comb through
neighborhoods that were wiped out by
that terrifying wall of water Redmond
Shannon reports
the first Friday prayers in derna since
the disaster that wiped much of the city
off the map
we lost a big portion of derna's society
says this man adding that he appreciates
the solidarity shown by libyans and The
Wider world
Aid is arriving but according to reports
nowhere near enough for a disaster of
this scale on Friday Canada announced 5
million dollars of Aid funding you've
got obviously Maritime access typically
what you do is you don't choose one
route over another you do all of them
washed out roads mean the people of
derna have to make do with whatever help
can get through or fend for themselves
the need for equipment to uh find people
in the in the in the floods in the
sludge and the the damaged buildings
shelter food key Primary Medical Care
the survivors in need of Aid each
sharing stories more harrowing than the
last
the height of the Waves reached the
fourth floor we could see the waves
sweeping people away from the tops of
buildings including my neighbors the
tasani family there are conflicting
reports on the number of dead reflecting
the chaos of a barely functioning
government in eastern Libya it is now
the focus of anger over the collapse
dams in just two hours one of my
colleagues counted over 200 buddies on
the beach near there this red crescent
forensic expert says decomp opposing
bodies do not pose a large health risk
and more time must be taken to
coordinate Mass burials the efforts make
it
for a loved one to laterally cover a
body and have the closure of a private
buyer
they help prevent people from going
missing forever a lack of resources
combined with a lack of proper
leadership potentially making an
unimaginable disaster even worse Redmond
Shannon Global News London
as you saw in those images derna really
does look like a war zone and in many
ways what happened is a direct result of
years of armed conflict and political
chaos Libya has been divided between two
rival governments since the country's
long-serving ruler Muammar Gaddafi was
overthrown in 2011 and with little
investment or upkeep a powerful
Mediterranean storm fueled by warmer
Waters exposed the fragility of the
country's aging infrastructure Eric
Sorensen reports
a country often at war with itself
neglected infrastructure and an
unprecedented storm was a recipe for
disaster in dharna
the Wadi River only periodically swells
and floods the dams built 50 years ago
above derna were the solutions
but Libyan news in 2020 reported on
heavy rains that destroyed roads
the infrastructure is really weak said
one man
consecutive governments have neglected
this said another what few seem to have
foreseen is that the dams themselves
could fail catastrophically from one
storm
the storm first gathered strength over
the warm Waters of the Mediterranean and
then turned Eastward over Libya's jubel
akhtar mountains a region that normally
gets about one millimeter of rain in all
of September received 400 millimeters in
24 hours the upper dam was breached by
more than a million cubic meters of
water water rushed toward the lower M
which held back 22 million cubic meters
of water the second Dam failed and
Torrance racing downhill some three
meters deep wiped out whatever was in
its way it has something that we'd never
seen before we were not used to this
incident we were not expecting it that
way Libya was not expecting it but a
warmer atmosphere and oceans are forcing
new expectations everywhere from
medicains slamming North Africa to
atmospheric rivers in the Pacific to
hurricanes persisting through the North
Atlantic as the atmosphere warms up it
just can hold more water vapor and if
you're close to an ocean which is warm
as well that just doubles or amplifies
the amount of water vapor and the
intensity of the storms Kent Moore says
Coastal communities in Canada and around
the world must prepare for what's coming
and not treat these new extremes as
normal it's not normal to get three
months worth of rain in a day a lot of
infrastructure dams uh you know roads
all those things will have to be
re-engineered to deal with these new
extremes because they haven't frankly
been designed for the level of extreme
events that we're seeing now and of
course what we'll see in the future what
happened in Libya and what's bearing
down on Atlantic Canada this weekend are
not dissimilar extreme weather events
that climate change is bringing with
more intensity and more frequency Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
in Vegas the house doesn't always win
coming up how hackers made off with a
huge payday after targeting some of Sin
City's biggest names
in Las Vegas some of Sin City's best
known hotels and casinos are still
offline days after being hit by a major
Cyber attack as Jackson prosco reports
the hackers have also made off with a
huge payout
in Las Vegas they say The House Always
Wins that luck seemed to run out after
this Trip's biggest casinos were hacked
I don't even want to pay with my card
right now I'm scared that they're gonna
hack all of our information at some of
mgm's dozens of resorts it headaches
caused long lines for hotel check-ins
and problems with key cards ATMs were
down restaurants went cash only and on
the casino floor slot machines wouldn't
spin when I tried to put that like pull
the ticket out and put it up just check
it out put it back in it won't take it
Casino giant Caesars admitted hackers
got them too hijacking customer data
including driver's licenses and Social
Security numbers Caesars paid a 15
million dollar Ransom to get its data
back there are no guarantees the hackers
will delete copies of what was stolen
that data can be used by people that
like to commit identity theft to open
new credit cards to get driver's license
to get Social security cards to open a
mortgage a group called Alf V has
reportedly claimed responsibility and
may have gained access by simply posing
as employees and phoning the IT Help
Desk
MGM says it's working diligently to
resolve its cyber security issue but
isn't saying much else I think I think
the most frustrating part for me was I'm
saying that it's business as usual
though things have slowly started to
improve the hackers have warned they'll
carry out additional attacks if
unspecified demands aren't met
if there's one safe bet it's that the
casinos will do all they can to avoid
another disruption
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
[Applause]
in the U.S 13 000 Auto Workers have
walked off the job striking against the
country's three biggest automakers
[Music]
members of the United Auto Workers Union
began picketing last night after failing
to reach deals with Ford General Motors
and stellantis that's halted operations
in three factories in three different
states it's the first time in the
Union's 88-year history that all three
automakers have been targeted
simultaneously the union is demanding
better pay benefits and job protection
and a Canadian Media company is making
major Cuts Metro land Media Group says
it will end the print editions of its
Community newspapers across Ontario and
it will exit the flyer business as it
seeks bankruptcy protection
600 jobs will be lost that's about 60
percent of its total Workforce the
company says it does not have sufficient
funds for termination or severance pay
it's six daily newspapers will continue
both in print and online metroland says
the decision is a result of
unsustainable Financial losses stemming
from the changing preferences of
consumers and of advertisers
next the story of another local paper as
it prints its final Edition
[Music]
it is the end of an era for our Canadian
newspaper that's been publishing in
eastern Ontario for more than 130 years
the last edition of the Glengarry news
was printed this week and our Mike
Armstrong was there
thank you
Ralph the last week hit Steve Warburton
harder and in a different way than he
thought it would over two decades he's
done just about every job at the
Glengarry news but when he was told it
was over he says it wasn't the loss of
the paycheck that hurt the most I
realize it's not just a job like being
the editor of this newspaper is has
become my identity it's a sad day for me
and for many people here at the glencary
news this was a Facebook video Warburton
shot after putting the final touches on
the final issue an emotional tour of the
paper's offices down there is
production area the eight staff members
were told the paper was closing last
week and the News started to spread
around town it's really bad for the
community oh yeah a lot of person talked
about that yesterday and everything we
were very upset because we get all our
news mainly from
the Glengarry news
the paper has been published in this
community since 1892. it's only ever had
three owners all from the same family
well that family now says it can't keep
it going I was shocked I couldn't
believe it
now there is blame to be spread around
government advertising has moved online
and big National advertising campaigns
like car companies have dried up add to
that a drop in readership Warburton says
young people don't connect with
newspapers although he did try I would
get pictures of them doing their Terry
Fox runs or the school plays uh
basketball volleyball we would cover
their hockey games as well and uh I
guess it just didn't catch on
now things like that are being covered
less and less across Canada because
there are fewer and fewer papers in
Ontario over the last 15 years about a
third of community newspapers have shut
down turning towns and Villages into
what some have called news deserts it's
quite dangerous it's dangerous for
democracy it's dangerous for the rural
community it's the dangerous for sense
of the placenta Community as well I just
don't want that to not be there anymore
the local mayor says there are efforts
underway to find new investors someone
or some way to get the paper up and
running again goodbye Glenn Gary news
otherwise this may be one of those
situations I love you
where people don't know what they've got
until it's gone Mike Armstrong Global
News Alexandria Ontario
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm far enough sir on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is more Creek it's near Madawaska
Ontario until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
have a good night
[Music]